right so we're gonna be handcuffed
together for the next 24 hours so little
backstory a lot of people don't know is
we didn't grow up in the same household
so for us to have only really spent as
much as a summer or Christmas together
we kind of keep in touch pretty well
considering that that gap in our lives
but we come together and now we're
handcuffed together for an entire day I
had just set up everything I was gonna
do for work and you go we're out the
gate clickers in my car which means we
have to get out of this car means we got
to get back out and then back in all
right after that we went to Chipotle and
then we get to Chipotle and we're in
line and this lady was like move rough
day it was only 45 minutes and she could
already see her face I mean but when you
walk into a food establishment with
handcuffs on her something is off
you didn't tell everybody about the
years of torment that I put you through
so we are actually half siblings but I
never got to see you very often and so I
would always be this close to you and
when we got together yeah because of it
I remember one time you tried to push me
down the stairs I won't deny that I also
won't agree that that's true so we went
from Chipotle and Luis to Sephora
Michael's girlfriend Savi was with us
and she really wanted to go to ice
before and I was like hell yeah I'm down
for it I guess
mati if my place is there outside the
door we're as comfortable in this air I
tapped out
shabby winds shall we definitely win
it's only been in the two hours and this
is gonna be the longest two hours of my
life feels like it's been 20 but we were
leaving before I might decide it out of
the blue he needed to take a leak I have
to go to the bathroom I have to go now
it is right there I'm not gonna lie to
you it was kind of a spike peak at that
point we were already in Sephora
who letting it rip I walked in there
with like head down I put okay I'm just
gonna look at my feet and just one guy
was like staring at you the whole time
like it kind of creeped me out he saw
you walking as he was about to walk out
and he was like no I'm here for this we
went to the nail salon and they were
very accommodating they gave us a pillow
they gave him a stool to sit next to me
they were very nice they also said what
the hell are you doing sorry we were
kind of we were kind of good about going
back and forth it'll be fine
okay okay you win you win you win you
win
but then my blood sugars started getting
low I got real hungry that was by the
time we got to the grocery store by the
time we got to the grocery store he was
just like I'm ready to go and then we
had to shop for the food we were gonna
eat yeah and you should never grocery
shop on a hungry stomach no you
shouldn't but you know you have to do
what you have to do when you're
handcuffed to your sister this is what
mama made are you ship do I need to come
with our mother and be like right this
wasn't good enough for Michael there was
she uses yes for everything you asked me
what I wanted to eat
I said turkey meatballs you said okay oh
you said meatballs
sounds like spaghetti and meatballs
perfect spaghetti and turkey gravy
meatballs does not sound good
first of all the recipe came recommended
from my friend who is a chef but was it
served with spaghetti
it's the meatball no it's a little first
of all I'm handcuffed to you for 24
hours and you can't give me two
tablespoons of turkey gravy
oh my recipe I asked what you wanted to
eat when we went to Chipotle we could he
could he and Ryan came over for Real
Housewives they dude we were trying to
cook your meatballs and spaghetti at
first it was nonsense and chaotic but
then we figured like you work that half
of the kitchen I work this half of the
kids in here and we kind of got it down
[Music]
so we're done hosting for the night and
we have all of these dishes I say we
just put them in the dishwasher
I was so physically drained and I ate a
lot so when I finally laid down it was
over I was I was done so does snap that
you got yeah like this because that's
how
do we snore my biggest thing going into
this I was like Michael is always late
doing something hey first of all always
something I wouldn't say always we were
late coming here we were handcuffed
together
you can't plan to start your day like
you normally started except now your
hand coat to a person you can
accordingly the same amount of exact
planet okay
we're not going back down this road
we're not going back down the road stop
being paid you still have to come to my
job and I went to your job yes so I had
meetings that you had to be sitting it
that's pretty cool
yeah it was cool sitting in and kind of
seeing how it looks in here is all kinds
of stuff going on is all right so do
this for my job okay sorry I let you
guys excuse me we won't be the BuzzFeed
hallway and I'm just gonna interrupt the
video that she's doing yes my snaps tool
I hope this is worth it for you this is
worth it for me I hope this is worth of
you for an entire day yeah really doing
this I say we go into your job like it
was really cool getting to see what you
do your side of things but the whole us
being fluid thing didn't work when you
were trying to be de no it doesn't
because you don't know those moves yeah
and you don't know how that whole
situation works I move a lot I move
quickly I definitely think this
experience has made me appreciate you
more oh sweet before I was just like oh
yeah this is my brother I see that you
have like these different nuances and
mannerisms that make you you yeah but I
didn't know we're there before vice
versa yeah you see that I get aggressive
when I'm hungry but I also have a
different appreciation for you as well
and I kind of also get to see you know
like what kind of woman you're becoming
as you're getting older and starting
your life and starting your careers it's
cool to see where you're at right now
you know where you were you were working
wouldn't did this again no no never
again we don't do this again call it a
dog are we done 24 hours yes all right
yes absolutely you do absolutely this
wonderful thank you I'm good
bye yes here you go free at last free at
last